I was a caregiver and a student so I
studied a lot of hours at this dining room
table because it is my closest point of
contact to her room so I can hear her
either with her buzzer or hear her call
my name so I can stop my studying
they'll get to her and come back to
studying easily
my grandmother was a teacher.
so this is four generations this is my mother my
grandmother my great-grandmother and
that's my sister as a child my time with
my grandmother and understanding what
education means has evolved from simple
"you must learn cursive" to "you must think
critically" you must not accept the norm
education is kind of your leg up that
will help you to be twice as good as
everyone else because you do as a black
woman that's something she really conveyed
to me can be mediocre so this is my
grandmother's kitchen and breakfast room
I am currently in the instructor's chair
in my grandmother's hand there's a
Highlights magazine she ordered a
subscription for me because it was
something that she thought was fun she
would sit here she provided lined paper
the old school lined paper with the
dotted line in the middle and I would
practice my cursive because she was so
upset that teachers were not teaching
cursive in elementary school by the time
that I got there she was not easily
impressed the world is not usually
impressed my professors are not easily
impressed being ready to meet any
obstacle with a faith and sense of self
that is so unwavering that I think she
gave me this is our living space my
sister and I brought a TV in here and
this was a great way for us to include
our grandmother one when we had company over
but to just kind of get her out of her
room oh my gosh
she loved Blue Bloods she also really
liked Family Feud and The Colbert Report
my grandmother wanted to live to see me
graduate but I think her her passing
just a couple of months before kind of
created an impetus of me framing my
mind that this gap year that I'm taking
before going in to grad
school should be about learning yourself
and loving yourself and just figuring
out what it means to take care of
yourself outside of the context of UCLA
student or a caregiver, daughter, sister
etc I would work on my research whether
it be writing in manuscripts creating a
poster doing a literature review and
just as I saw those things or as I found
things on the internet I would ask her
opinion and in that way she was able to
give a lot of feedback and input and ask
critical questions about my research
share our time share our energy through
love and that's what this experience
taught me how to love someone
unconditionally whether they're mean because
they're in pain right now I had to come
home and cook dinner and serve it and
make sure everything is good for the
next day when she died even for like at
least a month after I would wake up in
the morning and still have those thoughts
are the caregivers here is there
bacon for breakfast are there croissants
I live in this home because my
grandmother invested her time and
resources wisely and into us so ultimately
this life is about learning to bend
for others and to use your resources
your time your energy for the betterment
of your village